نجمه ثالثه في المونديال توسل لعبا انصار
المنتخب الفرنسي الذين هبوا لاقتناء الزي
المونديلي للديكه لكن الحذر من ان تصنع
اسود الاطلس بمنتخب بلادهم في نصف النهائي
ما صنعته بجاريها الجنوبيين يلقي بظلاله
على امالهم العبور الى المبارات النهائيه
لكنه مستنفذ طاقاتهم بقائد فريق المصاب
ولاعب حتى ان كان احتياطيا ورجعه وفوز
فرنسا بهدفين او ثلاثه انا فرنسيه قلبا
وقالبا لذلك ارجح فوز فرنسا لكن قد تحدث
المفاجاه لا يمكن استبعاده اي شيء لكني
اموله فوز فرنسا
في قسم الرياضه في صحيفه لو باريسيا لم
يستبعد الصحفيون سيناريو حدوث مفاجاه
مغربيه وتمحور طرائهم عن المباراه حول
الدعوه للفطنه وعدم التساهل والتحذير من
مكر زياش وحماسه رفاقه في ظل دعم الجماهير
الذي ينتظر ان يكون له تاثير كبير
او اليونان اذا فان حدوث مفاجاه يبقى امرا
ممكنا لكن المنتخب الفرنسيه يبقى مؤهلا
للفوز في هذه المواجهه
وينتظر ان تحقق مباراه نصف النهائي ارقام
متابعه قياسيه للقناه الناقله للمونديال
دون تشفير في فرنسا بعد ان هذا عدد متابعه
ربع النهائي الذي اقصد فيه فرنسا انجلترا
17 مليون
و700,000 شخص وهو رقم يعد الاعلى منذ
النهائي المونديال الماضي الذي فاز ديكه
بلقبه
ثقه بامك
انيه ارتقب الفرنسي قدما في حمله الدفاع
عن لقبه
حذر شديد تغذيه هواجس سيناريو الذي عاطف
باعمال الجارين الجنوبيين البرتغال
واسبانيا يثقل الاجواء الرياضيه الفرنسيه
في انتظار مواجهه مع اسود الاطلس في
الدوحه لطفي المسعودي الجزيره باريس